[Music]
here we go again sony have revealed the
ps plus titles for the month of november
2021. like always you'll need to wait
until the first tuesday of the month to
grab these which is november the 2nd
this month includes the first of three
psvr extras which we'll get to very soon
the first game of the month is first
class trouble a social deduction game a
better way to describe it would be the
evolution of among us crossed with
hitman let me explain there's a vengeful
ai bot loose on board trying to
eliminate all the residents it's the job
of the residents to work together
through mini-games and puzzles to
determine who the culprit is and survive
as long as they can we can lock each
other in freezes we can drop chandeliers
we can yield players into the vacuum of
space first class trouble offers
proximity chat meaning if you have a mic
you can hear each other when close
together but as that distance between
you grows the voices become quieter
until they can't be heard at all there's
also text chat and emotes for those who
don't like using a mic so if you want to
be a homicidal maniac and still keep
your friends first class trouble could
be the game for you oh and it's
available on both ps4 and ps5 the next
game is also on ps4 and ps5 it's
knockout city essentially knockout city
is dodge ball on the city streets the
mechanics are super simple and easy to
pick up and play without well any
learning curve knockout city takes what
you know about dodgeball and cranks it
up to 11 with super throws fake outs and
my personal favorite physical attacks if
you can't hit anyone with a ball use
your shoulder instead there's a little
emphasis on timing with a quick reaction
needed to catch the ball before it hits
you in the face other than that there's
not much else to it originally released
in may this year knockout city is
already seeing the decision not to be a
free-to-play game right away causing
player numbers to fall as micro
transactions take over maybe ps plus can
save this from going the same way as
rocket arena does anyone remember rocket
arena rip game number three is the
walking dead saints and sinners on psvr
virtual reality is finally getting a
little attention we are the tourists
arriving in town and in no time at all
you'll be running errands exploring the
streets and stabbing slicing and
shooting more zombies than daryl dixon
the gameplay loop sees more zombies
appear each day so as the bell rings and
you return home always know it'll be
more difficult tomorrow the story
although quite linear allows for some
on-the-fly decision making which are
genuinely tough to make and tougher to
pull the trigger these choices lead to
three different endings with other
versions of those depending on who stays
alive in your story so there is
replayability past the zombie culling a
quick note that on release states and
sinners only worked with the move
controllers and not the dual sense and
the average score was eight out of ten
not too bad at all and finally kingdoms
of amolor re-reckoning this is on your
ps4 although there is a 4k patch if you
play on ps5 kingdoms of amolor reckoning
is a cult classic he originally released
in 2012. back then it was given a nine
out of ten largely because the gameplay
was so satisfying eight years later it's
here again for a new audience to try
timing attacks and dividing enemies is
the core mechanic at work which is
impacted by the loot you choose and what
armor you decide to wear the choice of
switching weapons can vastly change the
entire experience which is useful
because there's a ton of quests to get
through easily 80 plus hours if you're a
completionist player and that's without
the dlc thanks so that's november be
sure to rank the offerings in the
comments below and let's see what the
community think i'm saying five out of
ten what say you see ya